let's have a look at uh the situation
here on the ground starting here uh with
the focus on mario pole heavy shelling
going on there can we hope and expect to
see some of that evacuation that's been
mentioned in the last couple of days
well i think we all finally started to
see encouraging reports that some buses
are able to leave from the local of
mario poll haven't yet seen anything for
definite that says that systems within
the city itself are being allowed to
leave
we know that previous attempts to
establish these corridors haven't worked
and we also know that there may well be
agreements officially to implement these
corridors but the situation on the
ground communication is very difficult
to those troops on the ground they will
be on very high alert for the other side
to take advantage of this so it is still
a very risky operation uh let's also
touch on what the uk mod announced
earlier today which is that they think
some troops are being moved by the
russians from georgia as reinforcements
is that something that we expect to
happen meaningfully
yeah so um i think we'll start to see
this happen more more and more um it's a
real clear sign that this would not have
been part of the original plan uh they
would have hoped to use the manpower
that they had initially committed the
fact that they're taking troops away
from georgia which is a very key uh
strategic area for russia implies that
they hadn't necessarily wanted to do
this i think we could start to see them
having to draw on troops that they
hadn't previously wanted to do as we
continue and it's another sign that the
war is not going as had been planned by
putin in the crowd let's uh have a
little look at uh the kiev and
surrounding area around kiev and and
again talk over the last week of of some
withdrawals from that particular area
and including around chernobyl
yeah so we've seen uh russian troops
withdrawing from around the northwest of
kiev and this was really very key for
them they'd committed some of their best
troops their airborne forces two
hospital airfield northwest of kiev and
they've started to withdraw
further north west and i think this is a
continuing sign that they've realized
that kiev will not be a city they'll be
easily able to take and they may be
therefore looking to focus uh and
redeploy down to focus on mario paul
which is by far their number one
priority the other thing we've been
discussing today is this uh explosion
this fire of belgae rod and whether or
not that is likely a ukrainian offensive
move which of course across the border
into russia
yes um so the attack was by two hind
helicopters a piece of equipment that
both russia and ukraine use the attack
took place at night and it's been very
difficult looking at footage to be able
to positively identify them either
russian or ukraine
what has been clear though is that the
attack had all the characteristics of a
raid it took place at night it was
focused on an oil facility to minimise
civilian casualties
this is likely due to ukraine wanting to
make sure that whilst they can show
their capabilities to strike inside
russia they don't do anything that will
increase russian population support for
the russian activity in ukraine
we can never rule out false flag
operation of course but at the moment i
think when you look at the messages
that's coming out from ukraine who have
not come out and denied this i think
that is probably what we would have
expected to see had it been an out and
out false flag operation